cleaning this Park in Greater Buenos
Aires is the only way these women have
of making a living they're part of a
social movement that helps poor people
around the country find a job we're a
cooperative that provides a service to
the municipality we started 12 years ago
it's the only job I've found they're
paid by the Argentine government around
130 dollars a month some people call us
lazy because we depend on the government
but we work and we provide a service we
also do courses and go to school for the
past several weeks the center of owner
situs has been repeatedly paralyzed by
organizations demanding more government
help the devaluation of the peso
currency has had a strong impact on the
price of food and social movement say
they do not have enough social movements
were born after the economic crisis in
2001 and they stayed and they play a
role in keeping the streets active they
copy how labor unions operate in
Argentina and they are an example of
what happens when politics reaches the
streets emilio Persico is the leader of
the Evita movement named after the wife
of Argentina's former president Juan
Peron he says his organization is
playing a crucial role in preventing the
situation in the country from going out
of control social movements are part of
the solution because we work where the
state does not some people want to
demonize us because we block a road but
that's not everything we do we are the
ones preventing people from running to a
supermarket and looting le de cachoeira
is part of the Evita movement
she says she worked all her life even
though she lived in a slum she's been
able to buy a home but now she can
hardly pay the bills I have to pay
electricity and gas and we can barely
buy food I have worked all my life and
what's happening to us is humiliating
since taking office Mauricio Macri
eliminated the subsidy on utility
services in an attempt to regularize an
economy that has been in the red for
years people here tell us that the
economic crisis in Argentina has an
enormous impact
in their lives they also say that thanks
to social movements they at least have a
job the problem is that in the past they
used to be able to fill the fridge with
food while now it's almost empty and
that's why many are on the streets these
days demanding the government does not
look away Teresa Waugh al Jazeera Buenos
Aires